F: Bernard Werber, Bernard Werber, Werber, Werber, Werber, Werber
Mais en fait, il y a tous les livres de Bernard Werber là.
Et même celui-là qui ne sort qu'au mois d'Octobre
Ouais, mais aujourd'hui je sors le vlog et les résultats du concours.
Salut les mentalos, si vous me suivez sur Twitter, sur Instagram ou sur facebook.
Vous avez pu voir qu'il y a quelques jours j'ai rencontré Bernard Werber
Eh bien aujourd'hui, on ne va pas parler de lui, mais on va parler avec lui.
D'abord de son spectacle qui va se jouer demain et qui est déjà complet, je crois, mais surtout de tout.
Attention, je vous met juste un cours extrait de quinze minutes,
puisque je sais que les vidéos trop longue sur la chaîne, c'est compliqué.
et surtout, parce que notre discussion ensemble a duré quarante minutes
alors si vous voulez voir les autres moments de la discussion que vous avez raté, vous pourrez à la fin
cliquez dans le lien, que je vous mets dans le descriptif, j'ai fait une vidéo juste pour ça je l'ai mise en non-répertoriée et elle est dans le descriptif
Dans le descriptif, vous trouverez aussi une vidéo non-répertoriée que je vais faire dans quelques minutes devant vous
Avec les résultats du concours que j'avais fait sur la deuxième vidéo de Pi.
Voilà, tout est dit
Alors maintenant, place à l'un des échanges les plus intéressant, qu'il y ait eu sur cette chaîne depuis le premier janvier.
Et donc je suis arrivé chez Bernard Werber. Merci de me recevoir Bernard
Merci beaucoup
B: De rien.
F: De ce que j'ai compris, c'est, on est dans un spectacle de moment présent,
puisqu'il y a des choses qui vont être improvisées, jusque là je me trompe ou pas?
B: Ha bah en fait, tout le spectacle est improvisé
F: Tout le spectacle ?
B: Au moment où les rideaux s'ouvrent, je ne sais pas ce que je vais dire.
F: Ah ça c'est incroyable. Alors c'est une prise de risque énorme
On l'a connait dans l'humour, c'est quelque chose qu'on fait en humour,
et en réalité il y a toujours une trame, une connaissance entre les comédiens qui font que la prise de risque est pas si Grosse
mais pour un "seul en scène" c'est la 1ère fois que j'entends parler de ça.
Et du coup, j'aimerais bien savoir quelle est ta motivation à faire ça?
B: La motivation.
En fait, j'ai fait avec...
les gens de la veillée notamment Patrick Baud
et Damien Maric
J'avais fait une apparition sur scène sur l'idée: 'Raconter l'histoire la plus extraordinaire qui vous est arrivée'
et j'avais raconté la 1ère histoire, celle de la Corse.
et au moment où j'ai raconté cette histoire
je me suis aperçu d'abord qu'il y avait
une intensité d'écoute énorme
plus importante que celle que j'ai dans mes conférences
une salle bondée
et au moment où je racontais l'histoire, je me suis aperçu que
ça fonctionne exactement comme j'essaie de le faire dans les romans
c'est à dire... je les tiens en haleine avec du suspens  et je les fait rire de temps en temps
et je... comment dire
je suis branché sur le groupe
je le perçois
et il se crée un dialogue entre le public et moi
et cette chose me manque beaucoup dans le travail d'écriture
parce que quand j'écris
J'imagine les gens quand ils vont lire le livre,
ils vont rire là, ils vont être inquiet là,
ils vont se demander, ils vont penser que c'est celui là l'assassin
ou ils vont penser que le trésor est caché là
mais je sais pas si ça va marcher
Et là je le vois en direct
Il m'est arrivé d'autres histoires extraordinaire
Bon... je vais pas dévoiler tout les sujets mais
F: Ah non surtout pas
je me suis retrouvé à étudier les fourmis en Afrique, ça c'est connu.
Mais ce que les gens ne savent pas c'est que je me suis retrouvée dans une tribu, qui était cannibale
et au moment où j'y étais, ils ont leur sorcier qui est mort
et pour l'élection du nouveau sorcier
ils sont allés chasser la tribu d'à côté
Et donc je me suis retrouvé, nous, le groupe de scientifique
français en.. on était pas en danger mais...
on a assisté à un truc
qu'on voit dans les films, donc Tarzan ou un truc...
et c'était vraiment étrange.
F: Surréaliste
B: Alors je raconte exactement ce que j'ai vu
évidemment je n'ai pas assisté à tout
mais... après à la limite je ne demande pas, j'oblige pas les gens de me croire
mais par contre je donne suffisamment de détails pour qu'ils comprennent que
c'est ce qui est  rentré dans le cadre de ma vie.
F: Ouais
Le fait que tu fasses la démarche d'aller sur scène en tant que...
de passer d'un raconteur à conteur, sur un storytelling vivant
B: C'est pas mal comme formule je vais... *rires*
F: Je t'en prie
mais...
mais en fait ça devient une évidence
tu vois, pour moi ça devient une évidence
euh.. je pense que tu vas être droguer à ça
B: Alors...
F: Assez facilement
B: C'est bien que tu me dises ça
parce que 1
J'avais la super pétoche quand les rideaux ce sont ouvert
dans ma tête, il y avait tout le monde me regardait, il y avait cette idée
'Bon maintenant tu as intérêt à être bon, sinon tu vas être ridicule'
*Rires*
Cette idée en grand, je sais pas si tu as déjà eu tout ça toi aussi
F: Ouais
B: Mais être ridicule devant plein de gens et en plus qui ont payé pour te voir. Donc
c'est pas bien
donc j'arrive
Je ne sais pas ce que je vais dire et puis je démarre
et après ça devait être à la...
première 1/2 heure
Je m'arrête tout d'un coup
et je me dis "Bon sang j'y prends du plaisir"
C'est à dire que je racontais l'histoire, je voyais des gens qui m'écoutait, qui me regardait.
Je me suis dit "Ça me plait de faire ça"
mais ça me plait dans l'absolu, pas pour gagner ma vie, pas pour la gloire,
juste parce que c'est ma fonction
comme un oiseau chanteur, il a besoin de chanter et il le fait pas avec un objectif
il me semble que j'étais à ma place
et maintenant
j'irai plus loin.
Je pense que tout écrivain devrait faire cette exercice
C'est à dire ne pas se contenter de l'écrit
mais passer à l'oral
Ne serait ce que pour vérifier, est ce qu'il sait tenir en haleine, en direct
une salle ou pas
F: J'ai une vraie question, aussi, qui... que je me pose depuis que j''ai vu que tu allais faire de la scène...
Tu expliquais dans un de tes ouvrages, je crois...
qu'à un moment donné tu construisais tes romans un petit peu en architecture, en cathédrale etc...
qui a été une source d'inspiration pour construire, moi, mes propres spectacles, je te le dis
et du coup, je me ..
à la base, je me demandais si tu avais essayé d'appliquer ça à ton spectacle
alors... j'ai une partie de la réponse là
B: La réponse c'est: J'ai essayé. Oui.
J'ai renoncé. oui aussi
F: D'accord, mais tu as essayé c'était une démarche que tu as essayé de faire
B: Parce que même quand je te parle là
quand je... développe une pensée
je pense tout le temps à une structure de type
cathédrale
F: D'accord
B: Parce ce que c'est un défaut et ça me pose un énorme problème
C'est que de nos jours
Le mode de conversation c'est
comme au tennis
C'est tac... tac... tac... tac...
F: Oui comme au ping pong
B: Donc moi y a un moment j'ai envie de faire tac, tac, tac, tac, tac, tac, tac c'est à dire développer une histoire, en la développant et tout
Ça veut dire que ça demande à l'autre
de... d'être un peu plus patient
F: Bien sûr
B: Et de nos jours, les gens n'ont plus cette patience d'attendre une histoire développée
et je crois d'ailleurs, maintenant que je te dis ça
J'ai l'impression que je crois que j'ai monté ce spectacle,
je me suis dit "Tiens je vais me prendre un temps d'écoute où je vais développer une histoire en entier
tranquillement et ça va être ça le spectacle"
Je crois que depuis que je suis petit...
je me sens frustré
de ne pas trouver dans le regard et dans l'écoute des autres
un espace suffisamment large pour que je puisse développer quelque chose d'un peu complexe.
Voilà, donc je l'ai fait par écris et maintenant je le fais à l'oral.
Mais donc il y a tout le temps une structure
En général, je fais
c'est plus qu'une cathédrale
pour moi la vraie structure c'est le corps humain
C'est à dire que dans n'importe quoi une histoire,
un... système
il y a déjà une tête
un ventre et des pieds
F: [chuchote] c'est vrai
B: Et même dans une cathédrale il y a ça
si on regarde les formes des cathédrales ça forme... il y a les 2 bras, le cœur,
F: Oui c'est vrai, c'est vrai
B: Il y a le cœur, il y a la tête, il y a les jambes
Et quand j'écris une histoire
je commence par faire la ligne de narration principale
qui prend la colonne vertébrale
la tête qui va être... la chute
donc c'est à dire le moment où il doit y avoir la révélation
F: D'accord
et les pieds qui est l'endroit où ça commence à monter
donc ça démarre aux pieds
ça monte dans la colonne vertébrale, ça termine à la tête
après les 2 bras... au niveau du squelette, j'allais dire c'est les 2 éléments d'histoire parallèle qui ne sont pas indispensables mais qui équilibre l'histoire
Une fois que j'ai mon squelette qui tient
et j'en teste plein avant qu'ils tiennent
je rajoute des organes
donc le cœur, l'estomac, le foie, la cervelle
et ça c'est les grandes scènes
originales
j'essaie de faire des scènes qu'on a pas vu ailleurs
mon souci c'est surtout l'originalité
Et une fois que j'ai squelette + organes
je mets les muscles ça fait des scènes normales qui font avancer mon personnage
ça va être le voyage, l'histoire d'amour, le...
les petits conflits
tout ça, ça va faire le muscle
et une fois que j'ai tout ça et que j'ai testé plusieurs fois
je mets dessus la peau et les gens ne voient que la peau
comme maintenant je ne vois que ta peau
F: Ouais
B: je ne vois pas ton squelette, ni tes muscles, ni tes organes
et toi tu vois pareil que ma peau
mais tout ça ne tient que parce qu'en dessous il y a toute une mécanique
et quand je regarde un film, quand je regarde une pièce de théâtre
je me demande tout le temps est ce que le squelette tient
est ce que les organes sont extraordinaires
est ce que les muscles sont bien foutus
et est ce que la peau va bien
et en tout cas je ne juge pas une oeuvre sur sa peau
donc on pourrait dire sur son apparence, sur son style
sur la... juste sur l'aspect extérieur
je juge sur l'infrastructure cachée qui maintient l'ensemble
F: Donc le spectacle c'est jeudi soir
si il reste encore des places. Je vous mets un lien dans le descriptif
vous pouvez cliquer
B: [Chuchote] Non il ne reste plus de place.
F: Ah c'est vrai il y a plus de place
B: Il y a plus de place. Par contre, il reste des places sur...
La pièce de théâtre
F: Ah oui
B: Qui va démarrer le 22 et là c'est une salle de 700 personnes
F: C'est celle que j'ai vu à Avignon
B: c'est nos amis les humains
F: Ah non, c'est nos amis les humains, en fait
B: C'est la...
Ah non c'est pas la pièce d'Avignon. Tu as vu la pièce d'Avignon?
F: Oui, oui, oui pas cet été, l'année passée
B: Bienvenue au Paradis
F: Oui
B: J'en ai fait que 2. Bienvenue au paradis et Nos amis les humains
Et Nos amis les humains c'est Jean-Christophe Barc qui reprend ça
C'est... c'est, enfin l'audiovisuelle, les autres formes de récit, que ce soit le théâtre, le court métrage tout ça
Ça m'a toujours intéressé d’aller voir
Je crois qu'on peut pas rester dans son art, se dire bon ben je vais tout le temps faire la même chose,
je vais tout le temps faire des livres puis je ne m'intéresse pas...
ni à la vidéo, ni aux séries, ni aux films.
Faut aller voir
Quitte à se tromper, quitte à ne pas être bon mais au moins... Tester
F: Ben c'est vrai, que moi tout au long de...  de...
de ma vie de jeune adulte à adulte
Je t'ai vu évoluer avec la bande dessinée c'était Exit je crois à l'époque.
B: Oui
F: j'ai pas...
B: J'ai démarré dans la bande dessinée
F: [Chuchote] Oui c'est ça
B: Ma culture est la bande dessinée
F: Ah oui c'est vrai? Je le savais pas ça
B: Je suis un enfant du Métal Hurlant
quand j'ai découvert Métal hurlant je me suis arrêté, je me suis dit
Tout d'un coup il y a la culture qui vient de faire un bon
et c'est devant mes yeux, c'est le numéro 1 de Métal hurlant avec Mœbius, Druillet.
A l'époque il y avait... Bilal.
Il y avait tous les grands on était réuni là dedans
et c'était de la bande dessinée pour adultes donc il y avait du sexe, de la violence, de la science fiction
On parlait déjà de Dick, on parlait déjà de tous les grands, d'Asimov et tout
et il y avait des couvertures extraordinaires
et je me suis dit "Ok je crois qu'en France, on est en train d'être à la tête, d'un système
Et bien plus tard c'est vrai que les Américains
ont reprit le... le système.
Il y a eu des films qui sont sortis de Métal Hurlant
et je crois qu'à un moment les Américains ce sont dit "Bon sang la créativité elle est en France, elle est en Belgique
elle est sur des projets comme ça, parce que il y a beaucoup de
Les Shuiten je pensais, les auteurs au book qui était des auteurs extraordinaires
et ils ont inventé le nouveau rêve
ils ont inventé de nouveaux visuels
et... donc j'ai écris un Fanzine et on faisait des choses dans l'esprit Métal hurlant
quand j'étais au lycée.
Et ça s'appelait 'La soupe à l'Ozen' et après quand c'est sorti du lycée c'est devenu 'L'euphorie'
et après c'est un scénario d'Euphorie qui s'appelait 'Les fourmis' qui a donné... Le roman
F: Ah c'est drôle
B: Mais j'ai démarré dans la bande dessinée
F: Et en plus,...
B: au niveau expression
F: j'ai toujours trouvé un point commun entre ce que tu écrivais et les bandes dessinées
dans le sens où à la fin de chaque page, j'avais toujours assez d'haleine pour retrouner... à la suivante
et c'est un vrai point commun
B: Il m'est resté un petit truc de la bande dessinée
C'est de faire des storyboards
quand il y a des batailles notamment
dans 'Les fourmis' il y avait la bataille des coquelicots
F: Bien sûr
B: Et après il y a toujours un petit moment où il y a des fourmis qui rentrent les unes dans les autres,
comme dans 'Les Thanatonautes' ils se battent en chorégraphie dans l'espace
Je fais... je fais du pré-storyboard en faisant les valeurs de cadre
donc je vais y mettre les plans panoramiques, les plans serrés
Les combats avec les... lumières et tout
et les gens vont voir l'écriture mais ce qu'ils savent pas c'est que moi j'ai l'image
F: Ouais
et.. parce que je pense déjà aux films
F: Du coup, tu nous la zoom, tu nous la dé-zoom aussi dans le descriptif
B: On peut avec les mots, donner des valeurs de cadre
il suffit de dire... "ses yeux étaient étincelants"
ou "sa main s'approcha du bouton"
et on a une valeur de cadre
et si on dit "la foule avança dans la vallée"
on a automatiquement une valeur de cadre
et c'est des mots
mais ça fabrique
de... du rêve dans la tête de ceux qui le reçoivent
F: Ouais
Est ce qu'il y a un projet défini pour la continuité des romans?
est ce qu'il y a une sorte de but?
B: Il y a 2 choses dans ma tête, il y a le conscient et l'inconscient
L'inconscient oui a un projet
F: Forcément
B: Mais le conscient ne le connait pas
donc je fais des livres
j'empile des briques
et l'inconscient sait que ça va faire un mur et il sait la forme du mur
mais le conscient se dit juste "tiens j'ai fini une brique, passons à la brique suivante"
Voilà, donc je pense qu'il y a quelque chose en moi qui est le plan global mais moi je ne l'ai pas
et donc là ma... même la brique 'Demain les chats'
qui va sortir en octobre
F: Au mois d'octobre
B: Est une brique qui a surgi par hasard
J'ai fait un roman...
j'ai fait un roman de type Jules Verne
et quand je l'ai relu, je me suis dit ça ressemble un peu à ce que j'avais mis dans 'Le sixième sommeil'
donc je veux surtout pas
proposer des choses qui se ressemblent
donc... le roman faisait déjà 600 pages
je l'ai mis de côté, peut être que je le sortirai un jour, peut être que j'en prendrai des bouts pour faire un autre roman
et j'ai fait à toute vitesse 'Demain les chats'
comme un livre d'urgence
pour parler de ce que je voyais, de ce que je ressentais de mon époque
mais raconter par un chat
plus précisément par une chatte qui est
extrêmement
comment dire
cynique, méprisante, mais en même temps
pleine de bonne volonté pour les hommes
Bon c'est un personnage étrange
qui n'est pas vraiment positif
mais un truc, qui j'espère qui est très amusant
et en écrivant le roman
j'avais mis comme...
comme compagnon de vie de ma chatte, qui s'appelle Bastet
un personnage qui s'appellait Socrate à l'époque
mais Socrate je me suis dit c'est trop facile, c'est, à chaque fois qu'il y a un philosophe on l'appelle Socrate
F: Ouais
B: Et j'ai cherché un autre nom
et je suis allé voir Pythagore, je sais pas ça m'est arrivé comme ça
et je suis allé voir la vie de ce bonhomme
qui vivait en -500 avant JC
et là je suis tombé...
en pâmoison, ce type est le type le plus extraordinaire de toute l'histoire de l'humanité
C'est lui qui a inventé le mot philosophie
C'est lui qui a inventé le mot mathématiques
C'est lui qui a inventé la gamme musicale
donc c'est à dire toute notre culture,
F: C'est ça
B: Vient de ce bonhomme
Pythagore
qui n'a laissé aucun écrit
mais c'est tous ces élèves qui ont raconté qui était le bonhomme
et c'est extra
et donc il y a eu en même temps, cette idée de parler de l'humanité à travers le regard d'une chatte
et parler de Pythagore, qui, comme un type, qui essaie de sortir l'humanité de l'obscurité
pour l'amener vers la lumière définitivement
donc ma chatte est éclairée par Pythagore
et j'espère que, un jour l'humanité pigera que dans ce bonhomme Pythagore
il y a... il y a pas juste le théorème de Pythagore
qui est vraiment un élément anecdotique de sa vie
Il y a un code de vie, il était végétarien,
il pratiquait la danse, le sport, le yoga. Il croyait à la réincarnation
C'est lui le premier qui a créé une école
dans laquelle les femmes, les esclaves, les étrangers étaient admis
ce qui à l'époque était révolutionnaire
et... c'est un type qui a tout le temps eu une sorte de... C'est un Léonard de Vinci
mais en plus qui a créé une école, c'est comme si Léonard de Vinci avait créé une école
pour qu'il y est d’autres Léonard de Vinci
et Socrate et Platon sont des élèves d'élèves de Pythagore
F: Il sort le 1er octobre
et aujourd’hui on est pas le 1er octobre et je l'ai dans mes mains
voilà je vous le fait voir pour vous donner aussi envie
Mais oui
B: Je vais te faire une petite dédicace
F: Avec plaisir
F: Je vous mets toutes les infos en ce qui concerne Bernard Werber dans le descriptif
de la vidéo, que ce soit, la pièce de théâtre au Palace
que ce soit la sortie du livre
les autres livres, les anciens livres
Si vous n'avez fait que découvrir aujourd'hui, vous avez du taf pour tout rattraper, mais vous allez être piqué, c'est sûr
et puis.... et puis le spectacle, peut être, renaîtra de ces cendres
B: Oui, si ça marche bien, si ça marche bien *rire* jeudi
je vais le refaire.
De toute façon, il y a déjà de prévu quelques dates en Province.
F: En Province ouais
B: Mais je ne me rappelle plus où, mais il y a au moins 5 grandes villes
qui sont prévues dans une sorte de tournée
et puis pour le reste, et bien je vais m'adapter si je sens qu'il y a une demande et ça leur fait plaisir
et que ça m'amuse, je continue
Puis si je sens que ça fonctionne moins bien je laisserai tomber et je trouverai autre chose
Mais pour l'instant... voilà c'est après demain au feu de la rampe
et après la pièce au Palais des glaces
F: Eh bé je te souhaite un gros mer** pour tout.
Merci encore de m'avoir accueilli.
B: Merci à toi
F: Il est tard le soir et il m'a appelé en me disant "Mais si, c'est bon tu viens"
Donc Merci beaucoup
et un gros mer** pour le 15 et je serais là.
B: Merci à toi
F: Salut Bernard
B: Et bonne chance pour tes spectacles aussi
F: Merci
F: J'espère que vous aurez apprécié ce moment autant que moi
J'ai donc eu la chance de me faire offrir, un des 10 livres qu'il avait déjà en pré-sortie
qui m'a gentillement dédicacé
Je précise quand même, si jamais faut le dire, que ce n'est pas un placement de produit
En fait, je l'avais contacté sur Twitter, il m'a gentillement répondu
Et à la base, je voulais lui poser 2-3 questions après son spectacle de jeudi
mais à la place, il a eu la gentillesse de me contacter
et de me proposer de venir chez lui directement le soir même à 22h. Il était plutôt tard
Ce qui montre, quand même, le côté très sympa du mec
Merci d'avoir regarder cette vidéo, dites moi dans les commentaires quel est votre livre préféré parmi tout ce qu'a fait Bernard Werber
comme ça on va comparer un petit peu nos goût.
Je vous mets donc dans le descriptif le lien pour les résultats du concours,
pour la vidéo de l'échange en entier
pour le spectacle, pour le théâtre voilà vous avez tout. Il y a juste à dérouler
N'oubliez pas de mettre un pouce en l'air
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo ou que vous en voulez d'autre du genre
N'oubliez pas de vous abonnez avant de partir et rendez vous demain à 17h
parce que le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
Tchao !
Je joue mon spectacle en entier le 23 septembre à la Garenne Colombe, c'est la date la plus proche de Paris.
Si jamais vous voulez venir, sinon il y a toutes les dates sur mon site